[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I have allergies and
my eye is really red and hopefully you
won't see it don't zoom in don't be a
dick uh I'm gonna continue uh hi Ryan
geez you're a well of problems today
yeah I am I'm well problems this this
dog I'm allergic to the dog I've got
these hours I went to the doctor uh
you know I got these eye drops I got
this cream nothing's really happening
I'm not sleeping I haven't slept much in
the last two months I'm up like I
usually sleep try to sleep eight hours
and now I'm sleeping average four and a
half five with the dog it's getting a
little better but um
something's causing my irritation and I
don't know it's is it just allergies
I sure hope so I sure hope so uh you
know I want to thank everybody
um for listening to the podcast and a
good shout out to my patrons you know I
talk about this a lot but um inside of
you and talk Ville we really have
success
some success or I'd say we're really
it's working because of the patron
family who give back to the show so all
I'll say is if you really enjoy the show
and you want to get back more go to
patreon.com inside of you and become a
patron I'll message you and it really
helps the show and there's lots of perks
I send packages like boxes of merch and
little notes I I write them all I pack
them and um
so there's that I do want to talk about
a couple little things first our handles
right
inside of your pod on Twitter inside of
your podcast on Instagram and Facebook
thank you Ryan yeah and a big shout out
to war next time my uncle it was a great
episode last week if you didn't listen
to it and you're here for Gates McFadden
I understand but I it's the first time I
interviewed a family member and it was
really fascinating he's like a pet
expert and author and people really
loved it so whether you know you want to
take a listen listen to me and my uncle
have a chat about life and things it's
interesting it really is I'm surprised
how interesting it would be not that he
wouldn't be interesting he's very
interesting yeah yeah he really was he
is
um a few of uh uh Charities I want to
just mention uh one is this charity that
I can't go to but I want to but there's
a it's a it's it's called crazy game of
hockey charity weekend and you can go
get tickets it's for the wild Foundation
charity and wild.com crazygame you can
get tickets there's uh it's uh July 8th
is a charity hockey game at 12 30 with
teams compiled of alumni current NHL
players musicians celebrities uh Oar the
band and Corey Wong concert at the
Armory pretty cool
um a lot of great stuff it's July 7th
and 8th in Minneapolis it's in Saint
Paul uh crazy game of hockeywild.com
crazygame oh I get it yeah yeah and also
just a shout out to food on foot for the
homeless problem that we have in this in
not only this country but in the state
of California my dogs are barking uh
foodonfoot.org if you want to give um to
the homeless crisis here in Los Angeles
great charity Rob who's in Sun spin the
band with me he uh is a head of
marketing or does all that also um
animal rescue mission my friend shira's
charity and I've never seen someone so
passionate about I mean it just stresses
her out constantly because she's always
saving animals and and she's like well
you know I want to act more and I'm like
she's done a lot of stuff but I'm like
hey this is like a perp you have purpose
you're saving animals you're rescuing
animals that's a huge thing so kudos to
Shira and the animal rescue mission if
you want to get back to that and Echoes
of Hope for foster youth that is an
amazing charity Luke and Stacia robotize
speaking of hockey
um
the inside of you online store is
available tons of cool merch a lot more
Smallville stuff coming new tumblers
that you have to see and that's there I
will be in Niagara Falls this coming
weekend hmm for Khan very excited about
that and then look for me elsewhere at
other cons and I might be going to Wales
again
I might be going to Wales uh I know we
had to cancel or the the trip was
canceled but uh I talked to Jamie the
promoter and we're going to see what we
could do in November try to get me out
there again we're working on it I just
have to see if I can if my schedule is
available but I want to say thank you to
everybody patrons you rock we did a zoom
with all the top tier patrons and it was
a blast and then we did another one with
talk Ville you could also get zooms on
talk Ville and tons of other stuff so
thanks for listening to the podcast this
guest is just uh she was phenomenal she
looks fantastic I hope I look half rage
when I'm her age
um Gates McFadden we talk Star Trek we
talk life we talk about career we talk
about she's so honest and open about you
know what it's like to be a woman and
you know as you're getting older I mean
it's you know it's hard enough you know
as a man and a woman but for women you
know it appears to be harder especially
for work and um
it's crap because she's phenomenal and I
could see her on so many things
um so if I did I have I said um a lot or
is not bad that's it's fine we'll cut it
out okay Jason cut my arms out
um you know my friend Connor he's Irish
and he always goes in instead of like uh
like we go uh I don't know he goes
um
yesterday was like so he goes in
I don't know why he does that but I like
it it's uh it's cute they do vowels
differently they do vowels differently
I I think he's throwing it forward when
you're speaking the Irish accent your
car's in the table cars in the table
sheep's the unhuman bastard speaking of
Irish I think Gates McFadden she Irish
I'm not sure could be Scottish it could
be Scottish it could be English
oh man I'm really bombing it doesn't
matter I love you guys enjoy this
episode I know you will we've had a lot
of Star Trek people on lately because
they're phenomenal and I'm gonna have
more if you're digging this so right
into the show and
um without further Ado let's get into
Gates Mick Fadden I love you lady it's
my point
foreign
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience Gates yes you uh you walk in
here and you're already a bundle of
energy and joy I mean I could tell
you're a little stressed because you're
traveling tomorrow yeah and uh the drive
over here wasn't as easy as you thought
I know where are you coming from without
giving your address uh well I was coming
from uh Beechwood Bronson area but it
was that I did not I thought I
remembered where the route was to
Jonathan's and I went up the wrong
Street I wanna
so I'm going up there assuming I'm doing
right and I went wait a minute this is
not looking familiar at all anyway yeah
I figured it out
um but I couldn't get I couldn't get my
GPS to work when I was up in the canyon
so but luckily the Amazon delivery guy
helped you out he did he said heads up
this is not that's up the road you know
the GPS in the canyon is it's not spotty
shoddy or doesn't exist in certain areas
here's the deal though do you have Waze
I don't I use it it's an app I use it
now the thing that sucks is now uh my
road is sort of a shortcut for people
and now there's more cars than there
ever was and so it yeah it pisses me off
okay frankly I'll keep that in mind I
actually when people drive down my
street fast I'm one of those old guys
like slow down right yeah so one guy
like stop he was going so fast and he
stopped and he started to back up I
don't know what was in my mind but I ran
after him like oh yeah and he sped off
like he's like this guy's crazy but I if
I didn't I think he would have been
trying to beat me up or no I wrote
that's why I love this show beef I mean
it is just so fabulous how beef I get
road rage you know I I sometimes have
and then other times I'm super polite
and I'm like absolutely just go right in
before me absolutely oh you know what
two of you go ahead I've got time and
then there are other times like don't
you you know like I will soon oh God
yeah do you like throw f-bombs at people
in cars no I don't not no I don't
usually do that you're not an f-bomber
no no I'm I'm uh get the rifle no I'm
not I I just really there are times when
there there's certain people who like to
just speed up and they've been they've
been going illegally and then they want
to speed up and get in before you and I
I suss them out because we actually
think alike but I've been I've chosen
that day to be kind
and so then I don't let them in and they
get very aggressive but it just doesn't
bother do you ever pull up next to
someone and just look at them yeah yeah
and do they ever look back yeah and do
they ever say F you yeah and what do you
do I just give them a peace sign peace
yep you know but if I'm wrong I always
apologize to somebody wow like I'll do a
yeah no I do a whole like wave and I'm
sorry and thank you and you know so
you're I would say just by hearing this
and hearing from Brent Spiner and
hearing from Jonathan Frakes
like this is one big family and I I
don't I don't I buy it but I'm like you
know every family has dysfunction oh of
course so you know but we you know we
actually are friends like
we know what drives us crazy about the
other person but then we also love them
for it doesn't bother for like like
Brent will say oh God that is so you
Gates right it's that sort of thing now
if that was my husband it would not be
done in that way probably right really
well you know oh that's so Gates
you know it's just it's different we we
kind of love each other for the
idiosyncrasies at this point
um and that's kind of cool you know it
is it's unusual because I remember at
the airport or something you and
Jonathan were goofing around like ah
Brent late again yeah or something like
that I was like you know I didn't know
like but you guys obviously joke and
have a report and and your son is he's
the Godfather of your son
that's right
he's the Jewish Godfather no don't tell
the Lithuanian priest though will you
please why because he it was pretty
funny I had two Jewish godparents this
was for my mother of course right and uh
that he he was really looking at me like
you have ruined this child's soul
and Brent has always said okay if you
die I'm bringing them up Joe which is
it's just funny you know I uh I have a
godson and I didn't want it in fact
really yeah so uh Tom Arnold good friend
of mine got you know kind of got me in
the business years ago I don't see him
very often anymore uh he's got his own
life but he's like him and his
one of his Ex-Wives called me and uh and
they said hey we thought about it and we
want you to be Jax's Godfather and I
immediately was like no don't make me
the God no nobody because buddy you
don't have to do anything just show up
at his bar mitzvah or something like
that you don't have to like you know
you're not like so in the beginning I
felt like you know I went to his
birthday I sent him presents and I'm
like I I I I'm not I can't I I just I
got I'm a single dude you know I
whatever so I felt this pressure and now
it's been a while since I've even seen
him is Brandt sort of hands on does he
call your God your your son and hey how
are you oh yeah I mean every every month
he sends him
um you know a couple Grand and uh stop
it you're a liar
no Brent is Brent's been great he's been
very much there every birthday he never
forgets he doesn't forget
um Christmas he always does something
for those two times and when he was you
know when it's when your son's growing
up in particular and when um Brent would
like he took him to one of the things
when it was Pinocchio and it was an
opening and he would do things with them
and uh even now no yeah they they yeah
they go and they sing songs together and
they play and no my son's got a whole
life and career how old is he my son is
uh going to be 32. wow yeah
and uh so yeah how do you look so good
I'm not I'm not blowing smoke
but how do you look so good because I'm
telling you yeah
I I have seen women a lot younger or men
that don't look that's my puppy that
don't look like you you just seem
together the way you dress your style
your face
you just have this like I don't know
this innate youthfulness about you well
well I actually
um what do you do what do I do well I've
always done a tremendous amount of
moving around I move I move like I I do
choreographer no I yeah I'm a
choreographer but I also did tons of
anything movement I mean I did tai chi I
did Karate I did Aikido I've tried just
about everything you can do and I just
like it so my energy
always is moving around like if I'm
reading something I'm sometimes doing
plea it's just it's just me you know
it's not that I'm a dancer I don't think
of that that I'm really a dad although I
could tap dance for you right now but
I'm not going to there's not enough room
in there but I'd say no oh yeah you can
do it I would just ruin your wooden
floors I wouldn't care yeah the puppy I
have Charlie is ruining my [__]
hardwood floors
well anyway I think I think it is an
attitude thing how do you eat I eat now
um I have these major gluten and dairy
allergies which just yeah they develop
for me too really yeah I I so I had a
guy when I was 24 in New York and I was
still teaching at universities then and
I was you know acting in different stuff
and he did this test and he said you
know you're really allergic like really
allergic to gluten and dairy and I was
like yeah that's like all I eat so and
yeah and and then he said no you really
are and he got me very scared so I tried
to go macrobiotic which is all you could
do then because if you go into a deli
there's nothing gluten-free or it's
without dairy I mean come on so um I I
did my best
I failed and then I went back to you
know eating gluten and dairy and then I
started to get migraines
and they would last finally for three
days
and the day I stopped gluten and dairy I
didn't have another migraine
so I knew that there was truth and then
if I would start to cheat I would start
to get a headache I could feel that that
was going to turn into a migraine so
it's a drag and and I I have to be very
careful I for different periods I was
vegetarian I don't eat any red meat and
stuff like that but I don't think that
has really anything to do yeah my
grandmother Blanche who's 95 in June oh
you named her dog after Blanche well
yeah and she's still alive uh and my
other dog was Irv who's named my
grandfather was like what the hell are
you name in a month I'm not even dead
you know but um Blanche is is one of
those that it it just defies like all
science it's one of those things where I
go she doesn't drink water get out of
here I gotta hydrate I haven't hydrated
in 94 years what am I gonna do she's my
kind of gal and she's like she'll eat
whatever she wants and she does this and
she all her Foods were fatty and oily
and I mean and so she's 95.
she's still walking around she walks
better than my 76 year old grandmother
wow or my mother
this episode is brought to you by better
help better help online therapy I talk
about therapy all the time and mental
health and this is what the podcast is
all about and I can't say enough about
better help they've been a great sponsor
and I think it's because it helps people
and it's simple and affordable and uh
you know I know how much therapy can
cost Ryan you've seen like you know
these guys in California or everywhere
it's just like they charge a fortune per
hour and it actually is added stress so
you're going into therapy stress but
better help to me is is just the way to
go
um if you're worried about you know this
the stigma is it's going away people now
I mean if you if people train to get
their muscles
your brain needs uh working out it needs
therapy you need therapy we need therapy
and you can talk about anything you'd be
surprised with little things that you
don't think are big and you talk to them
about a therapist and you're like oh
that's why I do that
wow he finds so much rewarding things
about yourself that you can turn around
you can change you could work on and you
have somebody here there who's a trained
professional and with everything that's
going on around us it can be hard to
focus on our well-being and many are
stretched thin and burned out from the
the candle burning you know both at both
ends and that's that's me and you forget
about you
um
therapy is is important you need caring
compassionate uh people who want to take
care of you and those are found at
betterhelp.com this totally online
source for therapy has helped thousands
find peace of mind and Direction during
these trying times betterhelp.com
understands we all need to develop
better coping skills and ways to set
boundaries to empower us to become the
best version of ourselves let me
recommend betterhelp.com if you're
considering trying therapy it's a quick
questionnaire and you'll be matched with
a licensed therapist and guess what you
can cancel at any time you can quit a
therapist and say that's not working he
or she is not working or they they're
not it's not working and go to someone
else find someone else that's that's
it's a process sometimes you get lucky
boom first one
um Ryan changed one time I did and and
now it's great it's great I've been with
this one for over a year but there you
go from the horse's mouth no offense uh
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
well you see I think it depends on your
metabolism you know it's like I have one
cat one's really heavy and one's really
thin and the cat who's thinner has this
metabolism that goes crazy and I think I
have that sort of a fat fast burning uh
metabolism but you know who knows I
don't know I I'm told every time I go to
the doctor you need to drink more water
I mean the woman who was my tie I was
going to go for a little tie acupuncture
and she said stick out your tongue and I
stuck up my tongue and she went
I mean the look of horror on her face
and she was like you need to drink more
water you know like like I was like okay
do you have some I'll drink it it looked
like I was gonna die I have to force
myself give me that water right there
next to you really yeah okay
we're gonna post it well you're making
me want to drink well let's have a
little drink I'm trying guys out there
drink water
I'm trying I really have problems I
don't really have a normal thirst all
the time right anyway you know why water
is boring well you know but you guys you
have to it's it's I never do I always
like uh a w root beer or grape juice
sugary [__] and it's probably where did
you grow up right you grew up in Ohio
did you I grew up in Indiana I was born
in New York but I grew up in a small
town in Indiana Southern Indiana all
right so there's something we have in
common yep you are Akron Akron yep
LeBron James and me and Pat Benatar
Akron General Hospital they've got a
great nights in motel that we used to
stay in on way to New York like what oh
really okay
I could have called up my folks I would
have you know you could have said they
would have housed me no they wouldn't my
dad
I almost said God bless us so he's alive
uh my father you know he was a Frugal
man he has a Frugal man uh but
we would go to these motels Ryan
we would go to these motels and it'd be
me
my sister
brother little brother Mom Dad wow two
beds and a cot in one room and the hotel
was probably 39 a night right my get two
rooms I know and not only that but I'm
doing armpit farts till like two in the
morning and my dad's pissed but he's
kind of laughing but he's pissed cut out
damn it see that's the kind of motel
rooms that I cleaned uh one summer for
trying to earn money for college yeah
really clean motels I did once you find
some stuff oh God they had a little
envelope that said little envelope for
the maid
I cannot tell you how many pubic hairs I
would find in that envelope oh people we
really do do horribly you know but they
were down with their friends drinking
parties and stuff and laying out pubes I
guess I mean that's what they're doing I
mean really it was pretty gross but it
did teach me
I don't want to do that for a living
yeah did you were your parents cool
growing up were you like did you have a
good family I adored my parents growing
up I just you know I looked up to them
they pushed us well my mother in
particular really pushed my brother and
me hard I mean we were like everything
like we had to be just do everything
cleaning studying everything everything
you know Girl Scouts had to do a sport
had I had to do violin the poor teacher
my poor Russian teacher he would go
it was arpad karinsky an r-pad and and
he'd go
you got to practice practice I would
have just done like 10 minutes before he
arrived right but there were just too
many activities and every night I'd go
to the dance studio for like hours after
school
um
and I think in retrospect I don't know I
never asked my mother this because it
only has occurred to me really late in
life
everyone's always freaked out when they
see how bad my scoliosis is I have a
really bad scoliosis really yeah and I
suspect that the doctor when I was born
said
the good news is she's alive the bad
news is she's got a really bad scoliosis
and I think my mother got me she had me
doing dance when I was two and a half
years old so it made it worse no it made
it bad you think it made a better
movement and God yes yeah I I understand
that because I haven't had a lot of back
surgeries a lot of back problems but
when I'm oh yeah like eight spine
surgeries but when I um when I'm
stagnant when I'm not doing a lot I feel
like it's worse when I actually go and
do things it's good for the brain but it
also which your brain and your the pain
are kind of connected arthritis is also
something that it's worse if you don't
move it's really weird you really have
to get the blood circulating and do
stuff I was told like 20 years ago I
needed a knee replacement right away and
I said nah not doing it and I've really
worked on just building up the muscles
around and I'm still good you know I
can't do I can't go up and down on one
leg like I used to but I could I can at
least do a ton of stuff I think it's
really about
I mean I don't claim to take care of
myself that well I just genetics well my
grandmother did when she was 100 she did
have beautiful skin 100. she yeah I they
we had longevity in my are your parents
still alive no they both died within a
year of each other it was really tough
my mother got um uterine cancer my dad
had ALS and was pretty brutal so I said
what was this this was right it's kind
of when I stopped going up for anything
and my agents said you're not going up
for anything goodbye
um that was like
I don't know 35 years ago wow it's been
a while since that happened 30 throat
medicine maybe that's too much yeah yeah
it's too much but you still so 20 years
ago or 20 years ago they say you know
I could feel this on you know with my
grandmother who passed and I could feel
it with my dog where you still think
about them yeah all the time I still
want to call my grandmother right seven
eight five oh seven five I know the
number but what's great is actually I'm
I was really off I don't think it was
that far I think it was like about 15
years ago that that happened maybe I
don't know how old am I I have no idea
but at any rate I have no idea I it was
just a horrible period and it was awful
because it was like right in that one
year they both I lost them both but
I would say about two years afterwards
like I felt them always with me it was
like okay they're part of me I you know
it's cool and I wasn't missing in the
same way like I'd sort of like uh I felt
their their presence in me right and
that was kind of nice but when I went
away to college
people I would hear someone on the phone
and they'd be going all right you [__]
yeah okay goodbye and I go oh my God who
was that my mom you know and I'm like
what it didn't even occur you never talk
like that oh I never did never did I
couldn't refer to my mother as she or my
dad would get pissed well she said don't
you refer to your mother as she well it
oh yeah you know you couldn't do that
where'd you go to college I went to a
school called Western Kentucky
University the hilltop person okay I've
heard of that I graduate from Brandeis
Brandeis and I taught at Brandeis for
six years you also teach at Harvard and
I thought I taught two seminars at
Harvard and I've taught yeah I was I was
not full-time faculty at Harvard I was
full-time faculty at like several
schools
um but I taught at a bunch like Brandeis
full-time
um wow I taught Marta Kaufman and David
crane really yeah did you want to did
you did you want to become an actor is
it something you had to pass before you
really wanted it you had other stuff no
I I
well I think I when I was a kid I've
said this in my podcast I mean I was
always building houses for my dolls or
making Air Force bases and stuff I
really liked construction I'd go in the
Dirt Pile I'd make cities I think that
had I been left alone to my own devices
that would have been my direction uh
like I didn't like playing with dolls I
liked making houses for them but because
my mother and father both
um loved
you know the cinema and all of that I
think that they they were kind of hoping
I would be like Grace Kelly kind of win
the Academy Award and then marry a king
I think that was kind of their agenda
for me die on a Clifford yeah she did
she flew off a cliff I know you know
she's my favorite I always think of what
she was Betty Davis and Grace Kelly
unbelievable yeah really really awesome
I agree I liked Barbara Stanwick too she
was pretty cool yeah she was pretty cool
um yeah I don't know I think like my
brother I mean he went to Harvard Law
School and business school the first
joint program they ever had so there was
something it's because they didn't have
the opportunities like my mother had
gotten scholarships to a couple of
universities and they needed her to work
to make money and I think that growing
up as they were both in the depression
period and stuff it just changes how you
think about stuff but yeah I I um
I was very close with them and they were
they were great
um
and my brother now is he's just moved to
LA for part of the year he's going to be
in La so that that's nice do you do you
think I'll get off the death subject but
um you know well look
you're a little older than I am not much
right but you've probably experienced
More Death than I have the obviously the
older you get my grandmother like is 95
and she has no none of her friends are
alive no no the people she loves except
her like immediate some of her you know
her immediate family so
I can't imagine it's like how do you
deal do you start to become numb and
just accepting I I just don't know how
I'll deal with Jeff I was talking with
Kate Mulgrew about this because she was
feeling that like oh my friends are
dying and and I had a really wonderful
friend who died a couple of weeks ago it
was just a fantastic actor Carol locatel
but
actually I've had so many friends who
are younger than me uh because I don't
know if it was from teaching or what
um I think when I moved to LA and left
my New York Community because I had a
real community of friends that were
there and it was harder to stay in touch
with them
um I think that changed but I also have
a I have very close friends who are
younger than I am and we're but we
always hang and I think that makes a
difference just having a good
cross-section of friends my friends are
not all my age
um
and then of course probably the next gen
cast we'll just all die at the same time
yeah that would make sense
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh do those thoughts keep you
from showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72-hour sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
I find it interesting and I hope you
haven't told the story but I know you
have but like
when you've you know you started acting
you started getting work you started
seeing like you know uh things are
working out I'm getting you know but
when you first got Star Trek next
Generation
I read that like is this true they they
fired you after the first season
well they don't call it firing they say
you're not asked back no you were fired
um no but you know what what here like
Maurice Hurley yes head writer and show
runner did not like working with you and
under her at her demand you were let go
is that true that was like he I think it
is true I but see I don't know that I
don't know that for sure but here's the
thing I think they had um like I had
said no to Star Trek twice before and
went to do a play for 400 bucks a week
uh with Linda Hunt so I was not I was I
was
I was a person who wanted it came from
this let's change the world let's do
something and I wasn't at all into the
business
aspect of be it theater even or uh
Cinema I didn't that that's not where I
came from I came from like okay guys
we're gonna make this the best we can
make and so many of the things that I'd
done had been collaborations like
complete collaborations with people we
would develop a piece and I loved that
so when I um or it was a brand new play
and then we'd have weeks to work on it
I didn't get this whole Hollywood thing
and there really are politics oh yeah
well I didn't know that and I think and
also it was a different time they really
they wanted women to look pretty and be
a certain way but they really didn't
want you to like
you know speak up as if you were there
equal I think so I don't know I think I
definitely pissed him off Maurice Hurley
because I I kept saying
why is it that I've raised this genius
kid will Wheaton's character uh Wesley
Crusher I mean the guys saved the ship
so many times right and and audiences
didn't like that in the beginning but I
mean clearly I had something to do with
it it wasn't just this dead husband and
yet every time there's anything even
possibly serious it's only the male
characters that talk to him and I know
he doesn't have a dad but all of you
ever have Beverly Crusher doing is oh
Wesley you know why didn't you do that
and I'm like wait a minute she's a
scientist I'm not buying this this is
like uh Leave it to Beaver kind of
um yeah mother thing yeah and so I had a
problem with it and I thought certain
like I thought Angel one was a really
silly sexist script of
um there's this planet of women and
they're doing really well and they all
happen to be really good looking which
is you know fortunate but then all this
is my kind of planet
and then all of a sudden son Will Riker
Jonathan Frakes goes down and they just
they they lose their mind because like
you know
it's a man it's a man I mean things like
that and I think that really pissed I
know it did piss him off and I and Gene
didn't love it either so especially
since I had been so I'm not sure I want
to do this in the beginning right so
that's what happened and and um whereas
my agent had said oh no your character's
like the third most popular character
blah blah blah I have no idea of of any
facts on social media when it first
started no there wasn't right but you
had sort of like people would still
write things or something right anyway I
have no idea but then I thought that was
over and I went and did a play in New
York and did Hunt for Red October which
was supposed to go into being in the
second movie and then Alec Baldwin asked
for too much money and they recast both
characters oh yeah so there you go but
but I did do a play that I loved in New
York City and it was uh very fulfilling
it was actually I loved doing yeah I
love that but when when but then they
asked you back yeah and see for season
three yeah and you were probably like f
you you know it was weird because they
they it was Patrick who first called me
and wow Patrick said it's not working so
well dot and you know and
um
would you consider coming back and then
Rick Berman called me I think Gene I
think it was probably Rick and Patrick
who talked the studio into having me
back or not the studio but I think Gene
was because Gene loved Diana muldar he
had worked with her for a long time and
it was more of that kind of the
character of bones but as a female
anyway
um my agent was a huge Star Trek fan and
she was more upset at not being brought
back than I was and so she was so
chomping at the bit um to get me back on
and I said I want to make sure that it's
really the character who's the love
interests of Picard
and she said yup yup same character
that's what they said and of course it
wasn't
um they it took a long time for the
character to sort of find its way
because it was sort of like Diana
maldar's character they had you know how
they get scripts ahead
and if I had been smarter about the
whole system I probably would have said
well let's see some of these scripts or
something but I just wasn't but I mean I
hope you fired your agent
I didn't fire my agent no I don't
because I just don't do that I know but
I don't do things like that really I
don't know I there's so many things oh
neither do I I don't do that I don't I
do it when it's warranted I I look I I
I've had two managers in my life yeah
that's it I've had uh usually I've
stayed with my last agent who is my
agent now for many years but
you have to know it's a business and
what they do is they want to get you in
something so they can make money and
then you're out of sight I know but on
the other hand I agree but on the other
hand you know she was the one who talked
me into going up in the first place
right I that was a fluke I was on my way
to the airport and she's from uh
something else I had tested for she's
like no you've got to that you know I
mean that was a fluke so again
um I think
what's weird and what I realized now in
my life
I'm putting together the fact that like
sort of three of the most important
things in my life have kind of come
through the back door like I've said no
no no no no and then finally I go okay
and they end up being something that is
on some level or another life-changing
there it's not like it's all about
things well one was doing Star Trek okay
because I said no twice and the other
one was I said no to Labyrinth a bunch
of times
um working with Jim Henson and then I I
said no to the podcast and I think what
I've learned from the podcast is that no
matter how much I complain I actually
like learning new skills and I like
sort of testing myself on you know can I
do this and what is that give it your
best shot like I want to be successful I
want this to work no I don't think it's
that no no I think it's more like what
is this is this something I like is this
something I don't like oh here's how you
edit oh that can really change how
something appears I love that I'm
interested more in it's like teaching
was that way I didn't go off trying to
be a teacher it was thrust upon me
because I was recommended by my teacher
and it just happened and it was better
than cleaning motel rooms right so
that's how the teaching started I was
teaching all different places in both
New York and Cambridge taking the
Greyhound bus and making paper mache
masks from my math class and you know I
mean I I worked my butt off for it but
again I got to direct and that's what I
loved I directed a lot of plays when I
was in Academia and I really think those
are some of the best things it might I
mean I really love directing um theater
a lot and that's why you know I built a
theater in La you know I mean it's it's
I didn't want to be really artistic
director of this theater but then the
only thing it's still here too yeah oh
yeah it's successful what's the Atwater
Village Theater and the echo a lot of
companies Now sort of take credit for it
but but I know it was me the first
person who went in there and I sold uh
almost all my memorabilia and I and put
the money into building it wow um and
that again is going back to building
something
go back to being a little kid I think I
love building things from the ground up
a lot I don't care if it's a theater
piece if it's you know I love
collaboration of that sort where you can
get into arguments but it's about
what the you know making the piece the
best it can be yeah and that to me is
where I am happiest I don't care if it's
even you know you're doing a recipe it's
like I love that kind of experimenting
trying to figure that out I love that
that that's inspirational I wish it's
not that I'm not like that
but I feel like
um I I I see something I have a great
idea it's hard for me to want it I want
it to come to fruition but all the work
it will take is daunting usually and I'm
just kind of like
I just I just don't think I'm gonna be
able to have the time to do that well I
hear you because I'm not going to make
the time to do it and it's just so much
you have to pick your battles and pick
your passions and pick your you know and
sometimes you're like you know I could
have put more work into that I could
have put or am I wasting my time on
something that I really don't love doing
right and that's something I've thought
about for a while with acting
you know it's something that I think I I
I I was good at I worked hard I became
successful so I'm like why don't I want
to do this as much why don't and I'm
sure there are a lot of different
reasons you know uh you know working
hard and then nothing comes it doesn't
do well it doesn't do well uh you know
not it just there's a lot of things and
then 14 hours on set all these things
that I just was like you know I like
sitting here yeah this is fun I get to
see Ryan's handsome face every day I get
to see your beautiful face meet new
people I'm good with people and I but I
feel guilty there's that side of me
that's going why aren't you doing that
and your agents and all these people are
saying dude why aren't you acting more
well I I wish I was acting more I would
really you love acting I love acting I
really do but you are acting yeah I know
but I mean I wish people would let me do
some of the character and funny stuff I
remember going in and doing a pratfall
in my spike heels like in early uh in
the 80s sometimes people just freaked
out whereas I knew how to do Pratt Falls
you're like a Chevy Chase in the eight
right I was I love that kind of stuff I
love
the I love physical yeah I love physical
stuff like that and I also love being
like a Margaret Dumont character I'm a
really good mean straight
um you know I I love all that thing what
happens when you get out here is people
see you as only a certain way you know
and it's a shame if I could see like I'm
looking at you and I'll be honest I
wasn't a big Star Trek fan I'm a Star
Wars fan so I've sort of been you know I
dabble in it and I I'm like yeah this is
pretty cool but I haven't gone in deep
like a lot of the people listening are
you know a lot of Star Trek fans or will
become or become fans of yours but um
uh where was I going with that Ryan
you were about I could see that or
something oh yeah you and you yes what
I'm saying let's talk about me but no
it's true I I look at you and even when
you were doing that Russian character a
little while ago I was like she could
probably do anything I mean I could just
see you as I mean I I don't know why
you're not like see I love to do accents
I mean I did accents when I did stage
stuff in New York and I I
I don't know I mean I think it's because
I started getting an agent and doing it
in the business when I was already in my
30s you know and I think I I did a whole
bunch of stuff that was just like less
on the radar I was working on
experimental projects and doing stuff
like that
I don't know
um yeah I think the European model was
one that I was
more comfortable with where you really
had time to develop stuff no one has
time to develop projects anymore I'd
cast you in something for sure that's
what's going on in my head thinking of
projects that I want I'm going to create
and do and like things that I'm do I'm
like there's got to be something
something for Gates no I know I mean I'd
write a character I think you're just
super talented and super fun to work
with and I I can't believe like you're
older than I thought when I met you at a
con and then at the airport right right
I was like she's probably in her early
60s you know
yeah it's just like you I I don't know
well I I mean I think I have never seen
the age that I really am when I was
younger I always seemed older and as I
got older I always seemed younger and I
that's really the truth like I I was
faking my age with agents in Ohio and
going to Oil City Pennsylvania at
falsies in my costume in sequence yeah
well I was like four fourteen yeah I was
like they call them falsies they were
like I don't know they different from
what they have now or fakies falsies
fakies exactly and then I would and I
was like 14 and my mother would pull
this makeup on me and um and I'd sing
you know I'd sing a song uh based on the
street you know and I'd start the tap
dance and then take off the skirt and
tap a little more and you know I'd have
I'd have like a trumpet player a guitar
player and a drummer and then the host
would say yeah let's see it again she's
the Ann Margret of Ohio do it again give
her another round and then I'd have to
think they'd want me to do that number
again and I'm going
your smile when you have lipstick on
your smile is fixed but you made
yourself look older yes older than you
were yes yes and by the way I could see
the Ann Margaret thing did you have sex
with Elvis no if only well
if you met Elvis one night after she
goes hey how you doing and you just said
hey let's go to my room I'll put the uh
I think I would have tried to to say
that why don't we just tell stories to
each other no thanks baby
not in a storytelling I won't do that on
stage well you know you never know when
he was young oh yeah but then you know
yeah then the drugs on the toilet and
all that stuff that didn't work out but
you know we were talking about cons yes
and uh that's where we met and we both
do the cons I met you at an airport
yeah we met in an airport first I think
I came up to your table at a con once
you don't remember me yeah because you
liked Star Wars say that you're thinking
of no but I can't I don't like Star Trek
I do I just am not as deeply invested
take a note on that please take a note
on that no but I wrote down sex with
Elvis and I'm on the next thing so okay
but
you know and I I know like for instance
one of my co-stars
um she have like a stalker she had
someone come to the show
oh really
got him out of the country like he
showed up and that was somebody was
sending these messages oh it's so creepy
and it's so creepy I know that you had
something like that and she was really I
was like what can I do I'll go handle it
I yeah you know I mean well can you stop
going to cons because no no no no no I
was afraid to go to them I was stalked
when I was teaching at University of
Pittsburgh
what yep and it was terrifying it was
before the stalker
um law was even you know before Rebecca
Schaefer was murdered and uh it was
really really scary
um he almost I mean he then when I got I
wanted to get out of there and there was
nothing I could do
um
it would just be everywhere he would
know where when my lights were off no
matter what he would I'd get uh I'd get
big missives that he would write and I'd
tear them up and then I'd just go a few
Paces away and then there'd be a new one
that would be in my purse I'd like how
has this happening it was like really
scary and he followed me when I changed
jobs and went to Brandeis and then he
had written all these open postcards I
didn't even know the people who had
hired me I'd met them once when I had
you know you you're sent and you're
supposed to be tested like do the
students like her you teach for a day
right you teach all the classes and then
they decide if they want to hire you and
I got this offer
as an assistant professor and um I
arrived there the first day in the
office and all the people in the office
are looking at each other like yes well
here here's some cards that have arrived
they're sort of personal and it was like
cards that he had written talking about
our relationship and all that and all of
which was fabricated and ladies no
they're like they didn't know it was so
weird and then
that
winter like in December there was a huge
snowstorm and uh I mean nine feet of
snow had fallen and we were all trying
to dig our cars out so I was on this I
had gotten an apartment in Cambridge and
there were some people we were all on
the street trying to dig out the street
and there's a guy who we had seen each
other and he taught photography at RISD
Rhode Island School of Design and we we
were doing it for hours and he said hey
you want to come up for my place was
just to have a hot toddy or something
and I said sure I'd never met him that
was the first time I'd met him I go up
the guy's pairing a drink and there's a
knock on the door and open up and there
is my stalker and he grabs me by the
hair I mean it was like amazing and uh
what yeah I mean here he is in another
state on a snowy night and he was he
looked like Tony Perkins in Psycho it
was like scary
and this other guy had a fake gun and he
put the fake he went and got it and uh
and then we called the police and the
police said there's nothing we can do
until he hurts you and I said well he
grabbed me he assaulted me and that way
and they said no but we yeah that
bruises and I went well no because you
[__] killed me so I you know yeah I
slept with a butcher knife under my
pillow for well how did it end it just
sort of trailed off he sent me Dead
flowers I just sort of trailed off she
had flowers and I never knew when I'd
run into him look the guy probably had
mental illness I don't you know I'm sure
that he's probably probably well I don't
I don't want to you know what if he was
really someone who would just I don't
know it was really scary though and um
that's why I didn't want to go to cons
because I thought I'd see him because
you're like almost inviting him
inadvertently like look I'll be out here
I'll be right right so I sort of was
like always trying to not do stuff like
that yeah oh my God I'm so sorry you had
to deal with it that has to be the most
terrifying like he thought he he owned
you yeah well no and you fabricate it's
amazing actually it's the fact you
cannot say anything he was a graduate
student well I shouldn't say more
details right because I don't want him
to anyway
they will no matter what you say it
feeds into something that they're going
to justify yeah so you just can't engage
and I'll tell you the this was the most
weird thing so I was teaching a class
called playwriting through improvisation
and
the very first day this was like my
second year I'd been teaching it there
and there's like 40 students and he's in
the class and he's like I have to talk
to you I have to talk to you right now I
have to go out in the hall and I'm like
well can it wait for after no it has to
be now and that's when it started and he
you know he just went
you know we are we are
uh lovers we've been lovers we have to
stop doing I mean it was just like this
whole fabricated thing and you're like
you have to go I was like this is my
clay yeah I mean
I was really young I was in oh my God I
was in my 20s it was like scary you know
and it's
people you just guys will not men don't
understand how uh invasive how oh yeah
intrusive yeah you know and I on a
smaller scale I've had a couple where
I'm doing stand-up and someone shows up
that she's always showing up where I am
hey hey and I'm like how's it going how
are you oh cool and this time I'm about
to go on stage I go I'm gonna go on
stage and she goes look grabs my hammock
we
we have something here and I go what are
you talking about I listen to your
podcast you're single I go no actually
I'm dating so much because no you're not
all right and it was intense I go all
right you've crossed the line
stop it
I've been a nice guy to you I don't want
to deal with this anymore I'm going on
stage goodbye and she just
and then I [__] off you know it's
easier for guys to do that that's why
I'm saying it's easier for guys to do
and maybe women can do it more easily in
my generation in the younger Generations
but in my generation it was pretty
pretty tough I mean because you know
when I would ever speak in that sort of
way I mean that's when they that's when
they'll fire you you know they don't
want really I think that and again maybe
that's just my projection maybe I was
just a complete [__] and deserve to
be no you know I I don't know one never
knows the other side of something but
um yeah it's it's awkward it's weird
when someone's
um all right let's go to a happy place
okay I hope it was a happy place the Jim
Henson working with Jim Henson what's up
maybe not was it because look you you
get this sort of you know in in my my
perception I guess a lot of the people
in the world like you know this quiet
reserved uh genius who uh is humble I I
don't know I don't know anything about
him other than he created the Muppets
and and wow this is great but I'm
looking at you right now and I'm saying
well maybe he wasn't the nicest person
to work with
um you know let me say this about
working there
um
I love Kermit okay Kermit is definitely
very special to me why is that
um
I think it's how he copes with being
green I think I think he really is a
Cooper he he knows how to just deal with
that
um
and he's just very lovable you know he
really is he um we communed it was good
it was there yeah no he was good
um I think
it's a lot like Beirut you go and he
lets people fight it out he really puts
a group of terrific people together but
they might not all work together well
and you have to sort of fight it out
um it was something
that it was
the only reason I took it was because I
had almost I had lost
two other fabulous jobs because I had a
skiing accident I was supposed to be in
Hannah and Her Sisters I had five scenes
part was just cut out and uh I also was
shooting a television thing and it was
going to be a two-month gig and I had
shot I think a day and I was recast
because I almost died but my life was
saved yeah and so
you know I mean that was a good thing
but things have been going really well
acting wise and that was the period
where and and Jim at see me do Cloud9
Tommy Tunes production of Cloud9 I was a
replacement cast
um brilliant play it was the first it
was how I Got My Equity card actually I
did it for I don't know quite a few
months and what an amazing it was the
triple roll it was fabulous and I and he
had seen me do that I didn't know it but
he had seen me do that and he knew I was
teaching at NYU Tisch at the graduate
program he knew I was teaching acting
stuff and doing comedy I was doing a
clown in the theatrical clown I taught
that for years
well yeah but mainly at that point it
was theatrical clown which was really
about finding your own comic Persona
your own point of view of the world and
um just being so present you know
um
and anyway
I think it was just this this tough time
for me and I went well I have to earn
some money and so I said yes I had done
this other so I said yes and then he had
me do this other movie sort of to try me
out and I loved that process it was with
a director named Gavin Miller it was
called
oh uh dream child with Ian home wow Cora
Brown and um Coral Brown and Peter
Gallagher and Jane Asher and I was in
charge of directing the fantasy
sequences for Gavin Miller so I would
direct all of these fantasy sequences
with the Mad Hatter and all of this
stuff and he liked that and and well and
then he would say yeah how about I like
this version I would do give him like
three choices he'd say I like this and
can you do that you know and it was
great and I loved the way he directed it
was it was super fun even though it was
a like a condensed period And I had
never done any of this before again it
was like you know you're building it
you're you're creative well I didn't
work with you know the animatronics it's
like you'd have all these buttons and
just to do the Mad Hatter mouth there
were seven people on it on the face
seven people you had people doing the
the jaw up and down then you had people
doing the lips you had people doing the
the eyes the eyelids anyone messes up
well exactly and and then you have three
or four characters characters uh in the
same setup and then you have we had a
live British actor who I would have do
the voice I mean it was complicated so
anyway I ended up doing it it was a year
of my life and then I was Frank Oz said
do you want to do Little Shop of Horrors
and do the plant and I went no I think I
want to go back and do acting thank you
very much and I loved Frank I loved Trey
but I I just it wasn't my genre what can
I say did you have him do the Yoda voice
no I didn't no I would have done it just
can you ask me in your Yoda voice and
I'll consider it
join me
I'm sorry that's terrible um it was
really fun working with David Bowie
though don't say that but Labyrinth then
you went to Labyrinth yeah David Bowie
was amazing he was amazing well he was
amazing I don't think I I really
I think I was
I think I was shy and I sort of I cover
up shyness by being business-like or
something you know yeah I think so I
think that had I really allowed myself
to just go wow
it was so cool just because he was um so
unpretentious yeah and so gifted I mean
there's very few people who could pull
off that character I wanna yeah you know
really I love David Bowie yeah
yeah I loved his last video my God that
was oh the documentary well no but his
last music video he made oh oh yeah yeah
Lazarus I mean it's just like amazing
yeah he was revolutionary he really was
he really was in so many ways so oh my
God you've done all this stuff it's just
unbelievable I could talk to you forever
um Picard this is what is this season
three yeah season three the final season
of Picard yeah right
what can you tell us the biggest secret
it's been shown it's done they've aired
it was yes with data data I always say
that data I know I love it it was a huge
reveal
well there were lots of reveals
the what's your favorite video of a real
besides data
no the reveals were all over the place
it's the fact that I had a son that
Picard didn't know about and it was his
son that's the biggest reveal that is
the biggest reveal that was the biggest
one when you read that were you like oh
my god well I knew that it was there
because if it hadn't been an interesting
storyline I don't think I would have
done it I think that might be true for
several of us but
um because the parts have been pretty
much nothing for my character in the
movies it was just like you know yeah oh
right we got to put it in a couple
that's got to be so annoying it's
disappointing I mean they'll pay you
yeah it's annoying isn't the word but it
is just you want to be more of a I mean
it's a part of it again it goes back to
the thing it's it's for me it's not
about
I mean I'm sure there's there's
tremendous ego I'm sure all sorts of
things but I know for me
I am happiest I don't care whether I'm
directing at that night at the 99 seat
theater 100c theater in Atwater Village
I forget to eat I forget I'm hungry I
forget if it's the process I get into
the process I really do I mean it's not
[__] I really do love it I don't
care if it's
teaching it's watching the people get it
you know you don't feel like you're a
real part of the process you don't you
feel that's like sort of
bored
you feel well bored or disappointed or
you feel ancillary you're just not it's
not very important and then you go well
okay people go well they yeah I'm doing
this and they're paying me that much and
I don't It's Tricky you know I would
much rather feel really great about the
part of what it is or be challenged in
some way but you love the show I do I do
I think it's I mean and I've learned how
to love it I didn't watch Star Trek I
didn't watch Star Wars either I mean I
didn't have a TV when I lived in New
York I know seriously but I think
um
Oh by meeting the fans we I've met some
really interesting people and you you
learn about the economy and the
socioeconomic situation of the United
States of America when you go to these
places and you know you you can tell
where you're near a military base or in
the South when it's like yes ma'am yes
ma'am yes ma'am and other places it's
not and there are places where people
obviously don't have dental care and
their teeth are just like oh so you
learn a lot and most of the people
really believe in the future and they
care about it and it's not so much
um
I don't think they just go oh you're Dr
Crusher I don't think so I think it's
more like they believe in what the whole
Michigan of Star Trek yeah I don't use
that word do you remember what's
Michigan the whole
Gestalt okay the Gestalt yeah can you do
a good German accent
um
yes I'm not going to do it for you right
now fine
um
um but it was a great experience the
Picard it turned out it was great I mean
Terry matalis I cannot shout his name
enough he really
um
was um
was just fantastic he's he was the
showrunner he was the guy who was the
head of it all and he really really took
care of all of us everybody has Great
Moments and that's really hard to do
with a big cast and we were and he did
it he I think he honored everybody's
characters and he he listened to
people's input on things and
um I thought I think they cast the
tiniest Parts brilliantly Amanda
plumber's amazing oh it is a lot of
parts of the most important really you
forget about those it takes you out yeah
it does and these people were like on it
they were so so talented every single
one of them I was very Blown Away by
them who makes you laugh the most when
you're acting with them on out of the
Star Trek guys oh I don't there's not
one I mean Brent's very funny it depends
everybody can be very funny uh Patrick's
even funny at times yes
lose the most Moody
well what Brent would probably say me
but others would say Michael Dorne
so I don't know could be a little Moody
but you guys get each other you just
know oh we do all right this is called
[__] talking with Gates McFadden these
are the top tier patrons it's rapid fire
okay I don't know this at all so I know
it's [__] talking with Gates McFadden so
I just ask you questions from the my
patrons oh I see patron.com inside of
you I love you thank you for all your
support as you know and uh see you rapid
fire if you want if you really want to
take the time to it Leanne how do you
feel about the progression of Dr Crusher
and Picard do you feel she is a good
role model for young women
uh yes absolutely I think she's ethical
and she does it you know she Rock she
she she can fire those weapons and she
uh walks the walk
Michelle I heard you got to work with
David Bowie and Labyrinth what you
talking about um you already talked
about that experience was there any one
particular story that you remember with
David well what I remember is he came in
looking really tired uh one morning and
I was like okay so we're gonna start and
do this and he went I'm tired he said
yeah Mick and I were up all night we
shot the video dancing in the streets
last night and they hadn't slept and I'm
like this this like the fan girl and me
going oh my God I wish I could have been
there and dancing in the streets
that's right that's amazing 99 more did
you take the chair with you or any other
items from set for Picard now they were
honest now I wanted the jacket I wanted
any of my jackets I loved Michael Crow's
designs for me I had some hot hot you
want to take anything
you know if I couldn't take the one
jacket forget it there was you know no
do you have anything at your house from
any of the Star Trek movies uh not
really in my house I have some stuff in
the storage thing that I will I always
sell stuff because I have a website and
I put my I put things for sale there but
it's almost always for the theater or
some project that's an original project
what is that website that people can
donate it's called Gates
mcfadden.com and I've got all kinds of
stuff up in there and you know they can
find out where I'm going to be and which
which conventions oh yes I like it uh
Raj tell me about a person or
professional goal you are currently
striving to achieve
uh well I
I can't talk about one of the things I I
would definitely uh well I'll tell you
what I'm striving to achieve is my
freaking remodel new construction in my
house that because of code has been
going on for three years and I'm living
in the back room
um of course the back room is bigger
than my New York studio apartment was
but
um but still I I that's what I love
architecture I love design so I'm very
very involved I know what I want but I
want to do I want to do more acting
that's what I want to do but I also am
trying to do some writing and uh we'll
see in this there is a project that I'm
I can't talk about but I'm just waiting
for those acting roles to just come on
in oh they will yeah DJ Kanto by the way
you were in War of the Worlds
well I was in the John Delancey version
right she said with the Nimoy absolutely
wonderful version of War of the Worlds
where they gender swap the lead yeah for
her and she crushed it got me through a
very scary ER trip before kovid always
wanted to thank her for that well
thank you for listening glad glad you
liked it Bill Murray once kissed you and
you were in the audience how'd you know
that somebody said that or you found it
unbelievable what that here's what was
funny about that is so some fans said oh
yeah on Twitter or something yeah Bill
Murray and I went no I never was kissed
by Bill Murray on Saturday Night Live
and they say yeah yeah you were in the
audience I said no no I wasn't they
showed me the video
and I couldn't even recognize myself
except for one thing I knit the sweater
I was wearing and I remembered the
sweater because it took me a long time
to knit it and I kept it for decades I
wore that thing out and I went it's got
to be me because that is my sweater I
mean that was like this very striped
weird thing was it a big kiss oh he went
right in yeah oh yeah no no he did you
didn't know him he just went up to you
what happened was because I first of all
it all has it's kind of come back to me
vaguely there was somebody in New York
who was
worked on Saturday Night Live who was a
friend of mine and she said we've got to
go I've got a seat let's do it and I
thought well that'd be fun sure I'd love
to and I do remember now that it was
very specific that we were sitting right
in the front row so I think she knew
that this was going to happen I had no
idea it was going to happen so he jumped
off the stage yeah and he played it's a
big old kiss he wouldn't be able to do
it now because yeah no but um were you
kind of like whoa
I was like Bill give me a phone number
we'll I'll call you I'm surprised he
didn't call you or try to get in touch
with you why would he oh you're
beautiful uh-huh yeah he's a he's okay
what do you mean I mean back then I'm
surprised like now you hear all that
stuff with Bill Murray and you're like
well I know you know well whatever isn't
it something I hate you know you find
out about your Heroes and hey I was on
The Cosby Show and that's right thanking
my stars that his wife's best friend
Carmen delavalot or something was on the
show that episode too so his wife was
around and I'm like I'm glad that was
happening because who knows Jesus was he
nice to work with then do you remember
he was like oh come on it's like three
lines or something I don't know all
right right
geez you had such a life look at you
such a life three lines here not that no
I mean look I look again I look I was I
was on small boats to get the keeps on
giving you go to college my other thing
is is that I have this little house in
France which I did the electrical plan
the plumbing plan I designed the whole
thing and it was uh and it's not a big
you know we're not talking Chateau we're
talking just non-touristy Village and it
took me 16 years to get it together and
I love this place it's really it's kind
of I I'm going there like so I'm I'm so
excited when I walk in yeah go tomorrow
yeah I'm so excited when I walk in and I
just go yeah this is me this is really
like
um
um I love the place it makes me very
happy so I can't wait to take the walks
on it and everything because I when I
studied I was the first person in my
family to go to any foreign country and
I got a scholarship to study with
chocolate clock in Paris so I went there
but anyway he was pretty pretty amazing
and um
that so changed my life and that was
really daring all my other friends from
Brandeis were going to get agents in New
York I didn't get an agent until I was
in my 30s I just didn't even I didn't
understand it like obviously I've had a
much better career had I it just took me
a long time to understand
so many things glass I'm going to take
any more of your time this has been
awesome and I'm gonna let you go because
I you have so much to do in your GPS I
hope to God will work
um no but do you think if it doesn't I'm
coming back and I'm taking one of your
dogs okay you can take the puppy but you
like you're so well versed you do all
these things you teach you act
choreograph you got build projects your
theater all this stuff it could seem a
little
um intimidating why to um well to some
men probably because you don't really
need them
oh it's you know what I mean like you
met I mean how long have you been
married
well I'm now divorced oh okay okay well
that feeds into that
um but you were married a long time well
I I'm I'm a Serial monogamous that's who
I am I happen to a doorman actually so
um you know I don't I think uh
I don't know I don't know but there's a
guy happening but does what I'm saying
is does a man that you're seeing does a
guy that you're seeing does he have to
do a lot of these things like be
Hands-On or do you date someone who's
not totally are you kidding really oh
yeah so have your own thing yeah just be
not I I mean be kind
just be present super handsome
yeah exactly no but I I really think
it's about I like people who
feel okay with themselves I find that
very attractive people who who really
like who they are yeah
um so that's important to love yourself
that's why I always say that that's sexy
to me that's that that is a big thing
and I think that's probably true with
women you know so uh what can I tell you
I don't know no I love it I was just I
was thinking because I think it was like
I was thinking of myself going man I
wonder if I could you know could I would
I be enough for a woman who who does so
much let me give you a strength test and
then I'll give you an answer okay should
I be honest with you no no I was hoping
you'd give me it I was like oh my God
you should give me a test thank you for
being here it means the world that you
showed up I knew you were busy and
you're like can we switch it and you
know you got your stuff going on so you
came here if you ever want me on your
podcast I'm there oh nice uh I really
adore you thank you for being here thank
you so much all right be cool bye
that was a lot of fun man I really
enjoyed her I I didn't know how she
would be and she was just lovely you
were here wasn't she just freaking
lovely she was beautiful and talented
and insightful and uh thank you Gates I
can go on about you foreign
again joinpatron.com inside of you to
get back to the to the uh the podcast
inside of you we need you we love you we
uh I think we thrive on
um patrons patrons support
um without them I don't know what we do
um also I just did a YouTube live with
my patrons that was a lot of fun I play
guitar I answer their questions
um all right thank you for listening
inside you online stores hot lots of
cool [__] going on right anything in
your life you want to discuss is my life
still going to better help
betterhelp.com inside of you I am inside
trying to drink more water
clear my throat I am too I am too
everybody's getting sick yeah lately
there's a Jess is sick
um
that's all I can think of right now it
only doesn't sound like very many maybe
I only have one friend top tiers this is
the top tier patrons uh they give a lot
to the show as you know patreon.com
inside you here we go Nancy D Leah s
little Lisa you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico
P Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua
D Jennifer Ann I just sent boxes to all
these folks I'm almost positive a lot of
these people I did it was their turn and
we sent boxes Joe comes over we go
through each box oh this is a three-year
Patron oh let me get a little more here
oh this is the first time this person
has a box oh okay well they're gonna get
you know some cool stuff and a little
note from me and we do that uh Jennifer
and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle
B correct Mike e l Don Supremo 99 more
Santiago M Chad W Leanne P Maya P Maddie
s Belinda and Dave H Sheila G Dave H
Dave uh Ray H right I like saying Dave H
because hey Michael how are you see I
always say he's just lovely he said I
love his accent he's very well you know
everything's going all right just
working you know working he's very calm
he's in the Rolling Stones he's a
rolling stone but I love Dave Hall I
love seeing him
hey
David Mickey [__] without this he's like
you know I listen to himself you and um
you know it's all right it's not
complete shite all right so Ryan isn't
it Tabitha tea Tom and Talia and Betsy D
where are you Betsy
I miss Betsy Chad B Angel M ran and C
Cory K Deb next and Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy D Joey M Eugene and Leah always
loved seeing you guys always well I've
seen all you Corey Heather L Jake B
Angelina Angela F Mel s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Eric H Shane R
Andrew M you know what's funny besides
clowns and Buddy Hackett
is
you know if I'm like if I have allergies
if I don't say something about it I'll
feel like you know a lot of something I
I don't like when people do this it's
not just like listeners it's uh friends
they'll say things like you know if you
ever have a friend you come you see them
like you know you look skinny are you is
are you okay I'm like oh God
or you look tired yeah I'm like I don't
if I know I look tired then you're
saying you look tired now it's in my
head yeah what can I do it stresses me
out you know on today's show you sounded
really s just not happy uh leave it
leave it
I love you I know you're concerned
but leave it that's why your friends and
therapists yeah you know my doctor says
uh Michael Dr hunger Michael you know
you you lost a little weight here you
might want to you know oh your enzymes
are you know they're not listening to
him you know he's my doctor Andrew M
L but Amanda R Jen B Kevin e pick my
nose real quick Stephanie K Jor L jam
and J Leanne J Luna R Mike F Stone H
Brian L kdb Aaron R Kendall L Meredith I
Kara C Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P
Estevan G Kaylee J Brian a Ashley f
Al V Mary and Louise L Romeo the band
Veronica Q Frank B the weird scientist
Chris D and Jen T guys I love you
I really appreciate you thanks for
listening to the podcast I hope you
enjoyed this one if uh you're new please
write a review
um And subscribe and spread the word
uh from Michael rosenbum here in the
Hollywood Hills of California
is Michael Roosevelt my rantez and I'm
also here this is
I couldn't do it without Ryan tabs no
yeah dude a little wave to the camera we
love you guys be good to yourself I'll
see you next week bye foreign